-Good evening I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing all right.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden appeared
last night on "60 Minutes"
and spoke about the ongoing war
between Israel and Hamas.
And you could tell
he was nervous
because he kept asking,
"How many more minutes?"
The Senate returned this week
from a fall recess.
Unfortunately, the House
is still in detention.
House Republicans on Friday
picked Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan
to be their nominee
for speaker of the House.
The vote was 81 "no"
and 124, "Yeah, fine."
Republican Congressman
Jorge Santos
reportedly got into
a screaming match on Thursday
with an activist
at the Capitol
while holding
a two month old baby.
So finally,
he's actually representing
the people
of Long Island.
Currently-indicted Republican
Congressman Jorge Santos
was seen leaving
a colleague's office
carrying a mysterious baby,
and when he was asked
if the baby was his,
he replied, "Not yet."
Which brings us to a segment
called, "Okay, but for real,
someone's got eyes
on this baby, right?"
♪♪
Look, I know there's a lot going
on in the House right now,
what with the no speaker
and the nomination of election
denying insurrectionists.
But for real, someone's got eyes
on this baby, right?
Because I don't know
what's happening in this photo,
I just know it's not good.
Jorge Santos is currently
under indictment for 23 crimes,
and by the look of this picture,
he's going for 24.
I mean, the man's running like
he just intercepted a football.
And then when asked
if the baby was his,
Santos opted for the most
dramatic possible answer.
"Not yet."
Is he a congressman or
a "Days of Our Lives" villain?
What does "not yet" mean?
Is he going to adopt it,
or is he going to do away
with the parents?
Someone please send me a picture
of this baby
holding today's paper,
because right now
I'm very concerned.
But at least now we know
Jorge Santos
isn't the craziest person
on Capitol Hill.
That title goes to whoever
voluntarily handed a baby
to Jorge Santos.
-This has been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The CEO of the movie theater
chain AMC posted last week
that a blackmailer
had catfished him
and attempted
to extort him for money.
"I know the feeling,"
said someone who just paid $40
for popcorn and a drink.
A woman in Australia
is recovering
after she tried to rescue
a platypus with her bare hands,
and was stabbed
with its poisonous spurs.
Though in her defense,
even the platypus
didn't know it could do that.
"Damn, I truly am weird as hell.
Every day, I learn
a new crazy fact about me.
Oh, I just laid an egg."
And finally, Netflix recently
unveiled plans to open two
so-called Netflix House venues
where customers can eat, drink,
and buy merchandise,
or more likely,
just look at the menu
for two hours and leave.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're up and running.